[Music]
this is Joy coming to you live in
Riley's mind get on your feet and make
some
[Applause]
noise anger let me at him fear mouth
guard people disgust no no no no that's
not ours sadness is in the house
yay orange who made the console orange
hello oh my gosh I'm anxiety where can I
put my stuff
this film is not yet
[Music]
rated our little girls growing up so
fast and things couldn't be
better what is
that I okay let's clear it all out it's
demo
day demo wait what's happening who are
you
people what's going
on wait wait you
can't hey hey what are you doing all
right she's all set get with what
orange who made the console orange do I
look orange I didn't touch it orange is
not my color not me hello oh my gosh I'm
anxiety where can I put my stuff a new
emotion wow oh I'm sorry we wanted to
make such a good first impression what
do you mean
[Music]
we
he